[Music]
Monday is the start of the spring season
and as the weather warms back up expect
to see more and more people out and
about enjoying our Parks across the
valley Madison Kimbrough stopped by two
in particular set to get some major
advancements all thanks to the city she
joins us live near the Clark County
Government Center tonight with the
latest Madison
with 75 million dollars of funding the
county is making it its mission to
expand recreational facilities one of
which is on the northeast side of town
and will make its debut this summer
it's so easy for kids to be on their
phone instead or you know just sit at
home if there's more things to do
outside why not encourage them to
continue going outside young mom Jackie
celebrating her son's birthday at
Hollywood Regional Park and says she's
pleased to hear that the park will be
expanding it's definitely needed it's
great kids you know want to play they
want to explore it the U.S department of
interior announcing 75 million dollars
in funding towards recreational
development which means more fields and
added Park amenities across the valley
Clark County Commissioner tick
segerbloom sharing with 8 news now what
advancements we can expect at Hollywood
Regional many soccer fields paddle ball
courts other things and this money is
going to come after that to create four
great baseball fields full-size baseball
fields and some other things but but
it's really going to improve the east
side Las Vegas which as you know has
always been underserved it's very
exciting to see the money that is raised
here in Las Vegas stays here and another
Park seeing some major upgrades James
Regional Sports Complex located in the
southwest part of the valley this park
set to get not just one but eight
softball fields to host the growing
softball community in the valley and
parents thrilled with the work the
county is doing to expand I love that
they're like investing in more parks and
in families and just community-centric
and outlet for your family to take the
kids out and get them out of the house
complex located way up North near
Decatur and Grand Teton is another
facility that will benefit from these
funds the county stating that some of
that money will go to their outdoor
archery competition range among other
things too reporting live Madison
Kimbrough 8 News Now